c'est la course contre la montre à
madrid pour s'assurer que le site soit
prêt en prévision de l'arrivée des
participants de la coop 25
le secrétaire général de l'onu partagent
un sentiment d'urgence
mais pour de toutes autres raisons
antonio guterres s dresse un portrait
bien sombre de la planète
le niveau de la mer n'a jamais été aussi
élevé les calottes glaciaires fondane
vitesse jamais vue et les catastrophes
climatiques sont de plus en plus
meurtrières malgré les scénarios
catastrophes
la tenue de ce sommet demeure importante
selon équiterre parce qu'il ya de
l'espoir
c'est une coque qui prépare le terrain
pour la coop 26 cependant la coop 26 les
états doivent présenter une cible révisé
de réduction de leurs émissions de gaz à
effet de serre on s'entend que cette
cible doit être compatible avec une
décarbonisation complète de notre
économie d'ici 2050
l'onu a fixé trois grands objectifs
limiter l'augmentation du réchauffement
de la terre à 1,5 degré celsius être
carboneutre d'ici 2050 et diminuer la
production de grs de 45% par rapport au
niveau de 2006 d'ici 2030
ce n'est plus un enjeu maintenant
technologique
c'est un choix politique de ces états de
mettre en place les mécanismes adéquats
pour tenter de limiter cet impact
température en bas deux degrés celsius
les efforts devront être ambitieux parce
que même en respectant les cibles de
l'accord de paris la température de la
terre augmenterait tout de même
d'environ 3 degrés celsius
j'espère voir les grands pays émetteurs
que les pays développés prendre leurs
responsabilités parce que c'est des
états qui ont contribué beaucoup plus
que les autres à la crise climatique
picc il dit drôlement ils en ressentent
moins les effets le canadien marconi
ancien gouverneur de la banque du canada
et actuel gouverneur de la banque
d'angleterre 2
viendra envoyé spécial de l'onu pour le
climat eller a comme mission de
mobiliser les milieux financiers à
prendre le virage vert et si valérie
michael à berne
radio canada montréal